estado de emergencia toque de queda
hasta el lunes y militares en las calles
así estaba la situación el sábado en
colombo la capital de sri lanka mientras
los ciudadanos tailandeses hacían filas
para encontrar combustibles medicamentos
y alimentos están cansados
la gente sale a la calle cuando la
situación es imposible esto no había
sucedido antes cuando los ciudadanos
estallan los líderes del país deben
actuar con cuidado
[Música]
este señor hace referencia a las
protestas que asolan al país en las
últimas semanas no dejan de aumentar de
intensidad incluso los manifestantes
intentaron tomar la residencia del
presidente votaba ya a raya pesca
protestan todos los estratos sociales
[Aplausos]
barbara tema no es un término mundial no
son una carga para el gobierno soy
acomodado pero mi riqueza no sirve
aunque tenga dinero no puedo comprar
nada no puedo ni volver gasolina de una
caja ganaba el país del sur de asia está
cerca de la bancarrota en la peor
recesión desde su independencia del
reino unido en 1948 ha pedido ayuda a la
fm india y china para poder pagar
productos de primera necesidad en los
últimos días se han sucedido los cortes
energéticos los embalses de producción
hidroeléctrica están en su nivel más
bajo además se han tenido que suspender
exámenes trimestrales por falta de tinta
y papel' mientras el gobierno culpa a
grupos extremistas organizados